>> ♪ ♪
>> Greg: THE CELEBRITY LIFE IS
NOT FOR HIM.
SHAQUILLE O'NEAL A MAN KNOWN FOR
BEING TALL IS RETIRING FROM
CELEBRITY STATUS.
IF ONLY I COULD DO THE SAME BUT
WHY DEPRIVE FANS IF.
THE NBA HALL-OF-FAMER SAID MOST
CELEBRITIES ARE NUTS AND HE'S
HAD ENOUGH.
>> THEY HAVE GONE INSANE WANT
DON'T CALL ME THAT ANYMORE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE OUT OF T MINDS.
HOW THEY TREAT PEOPLE.
WHAT THEY DO AND SAY.
JUST BASE I MADE IT, I AM BIGGER
AND SMARTER THAN ME.
JUST BECAUSE I HAVE MORE MONEY
DON'T MEAN I AM BETTER THAN YOU.
I WILL NEVER BE THAT WAY.
I DON'T WANT TO BE IN THAT
CATEGORY WITH THEM PEOPLE.
THESE CELEBRITIES HAVE BEEN
CRAZY.
I DENOUNCE BY CELEBRITY TODAY.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: AS A WORLD FAMOUS
CELEBRITY, I CAN RELATE.
ALSO LARRY GATLIN STILL GETS
RECOGNIZED AT THE LOCAL POLICE
STATION.
>> BECAUSE I DO A LOT OF POLICE
BENEFITS.
>> Greg: AND ALSO THE BIRTH
MARK.
>> YOU HAVE SEEN IT?
>> Greg: WHO HASN'T IT.
IT HAS ITS OWN INSTAGRAM
ACCOUNT.
TODAY MY ASSISTANT MADE EYE
CONTACT WITH ME AND I DIDN'T
FIRE HER.
I THINK THAT INSPIRED HER TO DO
BETTER IN BETWEEN HER BOUTS OF
CRYING BUT DOING BETTER THAN
LAST WEEK'S ASSISTANT.
WE WISH SHAQ LUCK IN WHATEVER HE
DOES.
WHY ARE SO MANY CELEBRITIES
JERKS THAT GO CRAZY BY AGE 35
BECAUSE CHASING FAME COMES AT A
COST.
FAME AND POWER ENABLES.
LOOK AT THE CUOMO BROTHERS.
>> REALLY!
>> Greg: THEY REALIZED THEY ARE
JUST A VAPID EMPTY SHELL.
WHERE IS DEBORAH MESSING?
>> [LAUGHING].
>> YOU ARE ON TONIGHT.
>> Greg: YOU ARE SEXUALLY
HARASSING ME, LARRY.
TYRUS, AM WITH SHAQ ON THIS.
I DISOWN MY CELEBRITY.
WON'T FLY FIRST-CLASS.
I WILL GO PRIVATE BUT NOT
FIRST-CLASS.
>> [SILENCE].
>> WHAT, WHAT?
>> YOU KNOW I LOVE SHAQ.
HE IS ONE OF MY FAVORITE PEOPLE.
JUST CURIOUS WHY YOU PICKED ME
TO LEAD THIS.
WAS THE HEIGHT OR THE ATHLETIC
BACKGROUND OR SOMETHING ELSE?
THAT YOU FELT MORE COMFORTABLE
ASKING ME TO BREAK THE ICE FOR
YOU TO MAKE A JOKE AFTERWARD.
I WON'T DO THAT TODAY.
THE THING THAT IS GREAT ABOUT
SHAQ HE HAS NEVER BEEN THIRSTY.
THAT YOU NEED MORE BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T GET ENOUGH OF WHAT YOU
ARE.
HE'S ALWAYS BEEN AT A HIGH LEVEL
AND HE WAS THERE BECAUSE HE
WORKED HARD.
EVEN AFTER HIS NBA CAREER IS NOT
AS POWERFUL AS WHAT HE DID AN
THE NBA CAREER.
OWNED BUSINESSES AND HELPS
PEOPLE.
>> Greg: A SHERIFF.
>> YES.
HE DOES A LOT OF THINGS.
HE IS IN A POSITION MENTALLY
WHERE HE IS NOT THIRSTY FOR
FAME.
MOST CELEBRITIES IT'S A SHORT
LIFE.
WHEN THEY GET TO THE END OF IT
AROUND 35 WHEN THE NEW ONES COME
IN, THEY GOT CRAZY.
THAT'S WHY THEY GET POLITICAL
AND DO THINGS.
THEY WANT TO SAVE THE WHALES BUT
STILL EAT BELUGGA.
THEY ARE OUT OF THEIR MINDS.
SHAQ IS NOT THIRSTY.
>> Greg: KAT, IT'S GOT TO BE
HARD TO WORK WITH SOMEONE FAMOUS
AND SELF LESS.
WHY DOES THIS SHOW WORK?
>> BECAUSE WE ALL GET ALONG IN
REAL LIFE.
>> Greg: THAT TOO.
I HATE YOU.
>> THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT PEOPLE
TO THINK.
>> Greg: WE DON'T CHASE
CELEBRITIES.
WE BEAT KIMMEL AND FALON.
WE DON'T HAVE ACTORS COMING ON
SELL PRODUCTS.
>> RIGHT.
BECAUSE ONCE YOU START YOU CAN'T
QUIT.
WHEN YOU BECOME AN ASS KISSER
YOU ARE ONE FOREVER.
YOU KEEP KISSING ASS.
>> Greg: YOU CAN'T UNKISS AN
ASS.
IT'S LIKE RINGING A BELL.
>> THE ONLY TIME YOU HAVE TO
STOP KISSING AN AS IS WHEN IT'S
TIME TO KISS A NEW ONE.
WHEN YOU GIVE UP YOUR PRINCIPLES
ABOUT CARING SOMETHING MORE AND
A PLATFORM FOR PLATFORM'S SAKE
YOU CAN'T GO ANYWHERE ELSE
BECAUSE YOU LOST YOUR
CREDIBILITY.
>> Greg: LARRY YOU HAVE BEEN IN
THE SPOTLIGHT FOR SOMETIME BUT
YOU HAVE NOT CHANGED.
YOUR INTERNAL ORGANS JUST YOU.
>> A GREAT FRIEND OF MINE.
DARRYL ROYAL THE FOOTBALL COACH
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF TEXAS.
HE TOLD ME YEARS AGO AND HE WAS
A WISE MAN.
HE SAID YOU CAN TELL WHAT KIND
OF PERSON SOMEONE IS IF YOU
WATCH THE WAY THEY TREAT PEOPLE
WHO CAN'T DO ANYTHING FOR THEM.
EVERY NIGHT WHEN WE LEAVE THE
STAGE AFTER OUR SHOW.
THE STAGE CREW IS OUT THERE AND
THE SOUND GUYS, HEY, WE COULD
HAVE DONE THIS WITHOUT Y'ALL BUT
WE WOULD HAVE TO REALLY SING
LOUD.
I CAN SING MY ASS OFF IF THE
SOUND MAN DOESN'T TURN ME UP AM
WE ALL HAVE PEOPLE IN OUR CIRCLE
WHO WE NEED TO DEPEND UPON.
>> SHAQ HAS ALWAYS DONE OTHER
THINGS FOR OTHER PEOPLE.
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHO HE IS.
HE GETS ALL OF THE ATTENTION HE
WANTS IS AN INDICATION HE
APPRECIATES THIS COUNTRY TO,
WHAT HE'S GOTTEN FROM THIS
COUNTRY, TO THE FANS IN AMERICA
TO THE MONEY THEY MADE IN
AMERICA.
HE UNDERSTANDS WHERE IT ALL CAME
FROM.
THAT'S WHY HE IS GIVING UP ON
THE OTHER PEOPLE WHO HATE
AMERICA AND THE FLAG.
GOOD FOR SHAQ AND THE HELL WITH
THE OTHER ONES.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Gre